Up to this point, we've been mostly ignoring the order of operations. That is,
we've been merely performing translations, rotations, and scales, without
worrying about whether one needs to be done before the other. After all, we
found that translations can be done in any order and these still add up to a
single translation. What could go wrong? The answer is, plenty. Order matters
when rotations or scales are involved. 3GS uses the following order to apply the
transforms on an object, scale, rotate, translate. In the scaling exercise, 3GS
first scaled the clock hand made out of a sphere, then rotated it into position.
Finally, it placed this hand to be just above the other hand. It doesn't matter
what order you set these parameters. 3GS always evaluates them in the order of
scale, rotation, and position. This is the default because it is often the
easiest way to produce the results you want. If you have something special in
mind, you may find it best to transform in a different order. That's possible
and, in fact, we will later see how we need to use a different order to make our
clock example look really good. For now though, we'll stick with scaling, then
rotation, then translation in that order.